this is Jack Ritchie with his parents
Liz and Charles when this photo was
taken he had already tried to find help
for his gambling addiction
aged just 24 he took his own life he
tried to get help on a number of
occasions
particularly from the NHS nobody there
knew anything about gambling disorder or
that it was a cause of death
um and the coroner said that the
treatment was woefully inadequate NHS
England says the proliferation of online
gambling means adults and children are
now bombarded with advertising where
they say bets can be placed at the touch
of a button and where there are
incentives like free bets to draw in new
customers
in 2022 a record number of people nearly
1400 were referred for help with
gambling disorders that's a huge nearly
80 rise over two years in response the
NHS says it is increasing the number of
specialist clinics it has across England
it isn't enough to tackle the problem at
all it'll be enormously helpful for
people who are already experiencing a
very serious mental health disorder but
what we need to do is stop them being
pulled into that mental health disorder
by the products and the platforms that
we know are so are so pernicious
UK gambling industry is worth 14 billion
pounds a year and we are several of the
major players for comment some already
do have gambling limits pay a voluntary
amount to gambling Charities and many
have publicly called for an
industry-wide mandatory Levy
last week flutter which owns companies
like Betfair Paddy Power and Sky Bet
said this
flutter Uki is committed to doing the
right thing and creating an environment
for customers to enjoy our products in a
safe and sustainable way
but people are more exposed to gambling
than ever before it's a 24 7 business
which for some like Jack Ritchie can
become life destroying
Catherine ever told see Sky News